[Música]
bueno pero mi historia empieza
comentándoles que yo no conocía a mi
abuela materna
nunca me llevó a pasear no me contó
cuentos no me compro caramelos porque en
realidad esa posición
antes de que yo naciera
y si ustedes son de los que piensan que
hay algunas muertes que son más injustas
que otras quizás consideran que esta es
una muerte injusta también ella falleció
a los 36 años
por una crisis de asma
y la verdad que tengo muy poquitas cosas
ya solo dos fotos
y esta es una de ellas en realidad es
esta en córdoba porque los médicos en
esa época la mandaba en los inviernos a
pasar a córdoba donde había un aire más
limpio
y si fue injusto por supuesto para ella
y para mí no les quiero ni contar lo
injusto que fue para
mi papá que se quedó sin mamá a los 6
años
pero no quiso la vida que yo igual que
mi papá estudian medicina
y soy no un monólogo especialista en la
respiración
un psicólogo se divierte mucho cuando
cuento estas cosas pero bueno la idea es
que cuando yo estaba estudiando
neumonología en el hospital de clínicas
donde preparaba los aparatos que se
calibran los espirómetros saben lo que
es un espirómetro
es un aparato que cuando uno sopla puede
medir toda la capacidad de aire que yo
tengo en el pulmón y nos ayuda a hacer
diagnóstico de muchas enfermeras
respiratorias
eso sería no me sentía bien está
tosiendo
el espirómetro y sopló por el
espirómetro y cuando sopló muy sale un
silbido en mi pecho en mi profesora vice
francisco
susan matiko
su forma tico
porque tengo que ser asmático
como yo voy a ser asmático
y como yo me dedico hijo del médico no
me he dado cuenta
y quizás a veces no es tan fácil darse
cuenta
a ver quién es asmático levante la mano
quien es amante ahora
varios neumáticos buenos hay más de tres
millones y medio de asmáticos en la
argentina
y lo que nos dará una mano
tienen mucho coraje porque la verdad que
decir que uno es asmático es como
reconocerse
fallado o defectuoso o limitado
no es fácil decirlo inclusive hasta nos
cuesta
decir la palabra asma nadie ve a las
personas usando un aerosol por la calle
y somos tres millones y medio
de hecho
los chinos hace 2.600 años la llamaban
respirador respiración ruidosa
fueron los griegos los que después los
llevaron a más
significa la respiración jadeante
desde ella hasta acá nosotros llamamos
de cualquier manera quien no conoce a
alguien que dice no yo tengo un resfrío
mal curado
una neumonitis la repetición principio
de asma
o los que dicen tengo bronquios como
para diferenciarse de los que no tenemos
bronquios
pero bien
el asma entonces forma parte del grupo
de las enfermedades innombrables
como tantas
la lepra la chiva
cáncer
tuberculosis convulsiones epilepsia y
todas esas barreras
cuántos miedos todos juntos no
no nos ayudan a poder llegar a tener una
vida plena
y ese miedo se basa en que la verdad que
sentís falta de aire es una de las
peores sensaciones que existen si uno me
preguntó un paciente que le pasa durante
una crisis o cuando no tiene tratamiento
inclusive puede pedirles que dibujen
esas sensaciones se sienten perdidos en
el espacio
perdidos
o
con un huracán adentro del pecho
tengo un huracán en el pecho
respirando dentro de un globo
o que el aire es un fino hilo
como el de una telaraña
o con un pez afuera el agua
pero en cambio cuando yo atiendo un
paciente que tiene 14 años y luego mira
tienes asma el chico obviamente está con
celular y me mire ya o querido que tengo
que hacer nada más pero cuando viene
acompañado
de su mamá llamamos tipo ni pálida se
asusta de hecho está pensando como a
tener asma mi hijo si te lo pasa de vez
en cuando
ya está pensando en sus vídeos si cambio
de médico
cuando viene acompañado la abuela la
abuela directamente se desmaya
porque en realidad tiene que ver con las
distintas percepciones que tienen todas
las generaciones de lo que es la
enfermedad
abuelos padres pacientes adolescentes
todos si tienen algo en común
nadie dice a dpa
e incluso nosotros los médicos para
disminuir el impacto decimos mire usted
tiene una bronquitis espasmódica un
broncoespasmo alérgico o alergia
bronquial o tiene admita tratar de
reducirlo cuando en realidad esa asma
es una enfermedad inflamatoria que
afecta a los bronquios variable en
intensidad y en el tiempo que produce 2
falta de aire silbidos y opresión
tratable y controlable y este paciente
cuando empieza el tratamiento se siente
perfecto es más vuelva con su auto mesa
no me falta más el aire y puedo hacer de
todo si se puede hacer de todo bueno
menos fumar de todo
cuántas trabajáis
para vivir pleno por no llamar a las
cosas por su nombre
entonces los invito a que un segundito
cierren los ojos y sientan como entre el
aire en sus pulmones conecten se con
esto
sienten como el aire entra
sientan como el aire expande el tórax
eso es un milagro
y este milagro lo tenemos que cuidar
y tenemos que empezar a cuidarlo
llamando las cosas por su nombre
muchísimas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]